yeah how about some
sunshine to wipe away that grumpy
face about some
Sunshine beams of Love brighten your
every so high as the sky silent smile
keep
time about
sunsh
me Seattle Hest is a phenomenal event
the biggest marijuana event in the world
you know the American people are mature
enough to be able to make their own
choices and the government this is one
area where the government really should
not be concerned about what people are
smoking yeah I think it's like alcohol I
don't think it's a big deal if people
want to do it it's fine and I think it
could be a good Revenue Builder if you
go over to that Booth
502 check out one of those little
clipboards go home go to your workplace
let people you know this is smart law
this is good citizenship this is how
we're going to end the war on marijuana
and then decades from now we can tell
our
grandchildren that Washington state was
the first state that started the end of
the prohibition on marijuana that is an
exciting
opportunity the chance to be
cherished
you always
dreamed
as Sil
smile keep
time
sunsh how about some
sunsh how about
sunshine me
7 6 5 4 3 2 1
happy happy 4 20 folks
happy look at you
guys oh